don't show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody so I've been getting a lot
of requests for a night king video about
his grand plans where he's headed next
what his ultimate goal is so this is
gonna be a little bit about where he's
headed next and where he's taking the
army of the undead and what he's going
to do about the rest of the world
because even though I think the series
is going to end in a very specific way
he's just not some bad guy who's coming
for the main heroes and that's gonna be
it he actually has a much larger plan he
actually can speak even though I don't
think that they're ever going to do that
on the TV show I think they just taken
the silent route and just chosen to make
him a little more terrifying that way
but I'll try to explain what's going on
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing Game of Thrones
until season 8 gets here and there's
giveaway stuff I'll explain at the end
of the video but if you guys didn't see
Neil deGrasse Tyson actually just posed
a really interesting theory about the
dragon fire that vissarion is breathing
now he said scientifically speaking blue
flame because it's blue burns much
hotter than red bar that the normal
dragons breathe which would actually
explain how he's able to bring the ball
down even though I know there are a lot
of questions about the whole logic of
the situation the holes in the wings but
I think the real explainer for that is
that he's being held aloft by magic so
the fact that he can still breathe fire
even though his fire sacks like where
the fire is generated in his belly
those were pierced by the knight Kings
spear he can still breathe fire because
of the knight Kings magic so I know
there's a lot of confusion about how
much power he has what he's able to do
his full scope of abilities as well as
brands is sort of the counterpoint to
that because even though Jon Snow
Daenerys have the Dragons the real idea
here is that brand sort of descends from
the children of the forest in the way
that the three-eyed Raven did gave him
his powers it is now sort of the
antithesis of the knight king even
though the show has only told us that he
just has the sum total of all knowledge
of history so if you haven't seen my
previous videos I basically explain that
because the knight king was created
through dark magic that the children of
the forest use his abilities and his
powers are a function of their abilities
so it's the same thing with bran it's
just that he doesn't know how to views
that in the TV show is probably going to
opt to use him in a slightly different
way but as we start to trace the army of
the deads path as they head south
towards Winterfell and then further
south the ultimate goal of the night
king at least in Westeros is the ace
card that he's trying to take away from
bran and anybody else that would oppose
them basically everybody that's living
what is that ace card well really it's
the Isle of faces in the gods eye so
I'll talk about the Macumber theory but
the hammer of waters is the most
powerful weapon next to the knight King
that the children of the forest were
able to use during ancient times you may
have heard a little about the hammer
when people talk about the shattering of
the arm of Dorne and holding on thought
magic the children raised the same
shattered the landbridge that the first
melody crossed into Dorne and that
failed the children brought down the
hammer of waters upon the neck flooding
and transforming it into the bog it is
today so in the Age of Heroes what
happens is is the first man migrated
from Essos using the arm of Dorne like
it was a land bridge they just walked
across in slow numbers they began to
proliferate it started to displace all
the previous inhabitants including the
children of the forest the other
creatures and things came to war that's
when you get to this big stories about
their conflict and eventually the rise
of the White Walkers but before that
happened there's this really amazing
quote about how they basically got a
whole bunch of green seers so not all
children of the forest have green site
it's incredibly rare like one in a
thousand people is born with Korean
sight so they got a bunch of them at the
Isle of faces sacrificed a bunch of
first men to the weirwoods like you see
them sacrificing the future night king
here to this weird wood and that's what
helped them invoke the hammer of waters
which even though they describe as a
physical hammer is more of a cataclysmic
act of nature here's how that passage
reads the children of the forest fought
back as best they could but finally
driven by desperation the little people
turned to sorcery and beseech the green
seers to stem the tide of these invaders
and so they did gathering in the
hundreds and calling on their old gods
with song and prayer and grisly
sacrifice like I said they sacrificed
thousands of first men to the weirwoods
I love bases in the old gods stirred
Giants awoke in the earth and all of
Westeros shook and trembled great cracks
appeared in the earth in the hills and
mountains collapsed and were swallowed
up and then the Seas came rushing in in
the arm of Dorne was broken and
shattered by the force of the water so
that's what they mean when they say the
hammer of waters so as cool as that
sounds that wasn't the last time they
tried to play that card they continued
to lose ground against the first men
like they'd broken the arm of Dorne but
by that time there were so many first
men in Westeros it was too late so they
tried to use it again to crack Westeros
in half it didn't work the way they
wanted it to and it wound up creating
the boggy area around the neck that the
crannogmen inhabit so eventually they
sort of moved in and took over that area
but the children of the forest basically
tried to crack all of Westeros in half
think about how crazy that would be the
hammer itself that destructive act of
nature that now bran is probably capable
of calling on is something that the
knight King wants to take away from them
the way he took away one of those
dragons so as has been suspected he also
has a form of greenside it might not
work exactly like brands but I do
believe that he was able to see the
Dragons and enact all these plans so
that he could take that away from
tenaris which sort of explains some of
the stupidity in the Magnificent Seven
in their mission north of the wall the
knight King had the chains ready to go
so I know there are a lot of logic
questions about that situation so were
he able to fly down to the Isle of faces
destroy all the weirwoods that would
take away brands ability to wash the
army of the Dead away like literally you
call upon the hammer of waters you could
wash away the army of the dead with a
giant tide of water because they can't
swim that was the primary excuse that
you're unused when he bailed on them in
the finale even though that wound up
being a bit of a lie
they swim no good I'm taking the iron
feet back to darkness but the Isle of
faces just continues to be a really
important strategic place next to
Winterfell
Winterfell is a literal army strategic
place where you have a bunch of troops
the Isle of faces just remains a much
more magically strategic place so let me
know in the comments how much lore do
you think that Samwell
is going to be scanning brands brain for
in between seasons now expecting that
there's only six episodes there's
probably a lot of mythology that they're
going to brush over like you'll just
have to assume that a lot of characters
have conversations off screen the same
way they did during season seven like
you have this big romance playing out
between John and Daenerys but you only
really see them together in moments like
this a handful of times during the
course of the season so I think it's
safe to assume starting with this
mythology around Jon Snow's parentage
Rhaegar Targaryen they've also started
to look into other things that can help
take down the night king in the White
Walkers going a little further south
King's Landing is still a very strategic
place Cersei is going to be marshalling
the golden company and even though we
have a lot of ideas about what's going
to happen to them ultimately the 19
could choose to do one of two things
because now that he has vissarion he
could actually fly like even if you
don't assume mass transit system of
Westeros he could still fly incredibly
fast down to the south
start turning people and have them March
up north simultaneously while his
northern army that's just crossed south
of the wall heads down south to
Winterfell so you have this two-pronged
attack coming from both sides but even
though he does have that dragon now it
doesn't look like he's in any particular
rush he has the White Walkers that are
leading the army at a snail's pace
they'll snake their way down south
through the last hearts then through the
karhold then back around to Winterfell
and I'm not expecting to see them hit
bear island just because they can't swim
that was a big thing so it wouldn't make
too much sense for them to go over there
but I do think that it's going to take
them at least half of the season to get
anywhere close to Winterfell I do think
they're gonna continue to march
incredibly slowly well the night king
spends most of his time using vissarion
to take down the castles so I do think
that we'll get to see that but they'll
have to do it with CG and models but
we'll get to see a version of what Aegon
did to Harrenhal way back during the war
of conquest so that was one of the first
targets that he hid Harrenhal had just
finished being built
Harrenhal was so proud of himself it was
supposed to be the biggest castle in the
realm egg on flew right up with his
dragons and melted it halfway to the
ground and that's why the stones still
look like they've been melted when you
see it in the first couple of seasons on
the TV show so I think we'll get to see
that
happen with the night king Vissarion in
some of these northern castles it
what'll happen is is there'll be some
new Game of Thrones this weekend the
Rick and Morty finale is happening so
just check the top comment that I pin in
the comments for announcements but I'll
say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Carlos you win a copy of
the season 7 DVD please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there's a
new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
Game of Thrones
you can click here to learn all about
the awesome stuff they just announced
for the season 8 production it's crazy
and you can click here to rewatch that
Targaryen prequel thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you